hundreds of thousands of Muslim devotees
from all walks of life from all around
the world have gathered in Bangladesh
for three days of prayers and sermons
bisho istama or Global Congregation of
Muslims held each year since 1967 aims
to revive the tenets of Islam and
promote peace
I along with hundreds of others came all
the way from Palestine on a long journey
to learn more about the essence of Islam
and its teachings
the estimate is considered an expression
of Muslim Unity solidarity love and
respect
we came here to learn the meaning of
life about why we were born we all have
to return to Allah we have to understand
all these teachings of our prophet and
the Quran we can't learn these things by
staying home we have to travel
Muslim devotees spent three days crammed
into tents in five square kilometer area
those who couldn't find Space on istama
ground camped on the footpaths
we have heard so much about the large
ichima gatherings in Bangladesh now we
are very happy to be here and
participate in this auspicious religious
gathering the large number of worshipers
is a challenge for authorities there's a
strong security presence and Healthcare
and other basic services are provided
this is a very large Gathering of people
from everywhere it can be difficult but
people are in a good mood and smiling
we're here to please Allah so it's not a
hardship for us
it is estimated that more than 3 million
devotees took part this year the first
phase of one of the largest Muslim
gatherings in the world is to end this
Sunday with hundreds of thousands of
muslims praying for Global Peace divine
blessing and the Revival of Islamic
valuesipur